[Musik]
si
hallo herzlich willkommen salis welt
heute gibt es ein video mit drei
verschiedenen eis rezepten
ich werde immer wieder gefragt sally
mach doch mal was gesundes und gesundes
rezept gerade bei den temperaturen
draußen habe ich auch gerne eine
erfrischung aber eben nicht wirklich
unbedingt eine mit viel zucker also
machen wir heute 31 rezepte und ich
starte direkt mit dem ersten mit dem
wassermelonen eis so könnt ihr nämlich
wirklich ein wassereis machen ohne
zugesetzten zucker
ihr braucht dafür eine wassermelone und
wenn ihr wollt noch eine limette
das nehmen wir zuerst die wassermelone
und halbiert sie nicht schön rot aber es
ist trotzdem lecker und jetzt nehmt ihr
einfach direkt einen löffel
ich kann die wassermelone aushöhlen und
das fruchtfleisch rausholen sonst
hauskatzen und ich habe jetzt hier eine
ohne kerne das ist hier ganz praktisch
und einfach direkt in den mix behälter
geben
ich habe übrigens die wassermelone
halbiert und nicht gefüttert werden
natürlich einfacher weil ich später die
wassermelonen helfen als gefäß benutze
es wenn dann die salier schale
und wenn ihr wollt neben die jetzt noch
eine limette da einfach nur darauf
achten dass die schale zum verzehr
geeignet ist und die limettenschale dazu
geben sie passt geschmacklich super und
dann kurz pürieren
jetzt nehmen die einfach ein großes
flaches gefäß füllt diesen wassermelonen
drink hier ein und fritz ein und alle
stunde werde ich einfach mal rangehen
und das ganze durchführen so damit sich
diese kleinen süßen kristalle bilden und
so eine art flasche entsteht und es
dauert dann insgesamt je nachdem was für
ein gefäß ihr habt wie groß die
wassermelone ist zwischen vier und sechs
stunden
das erste eis ist im gefrierfach jetzt
kommt die zweite variante eine etwas
gesündere variante
ich nehme zwar ein bisschen schokolade
aber ich nehme zar peter schokolade also
eine schokolade mit relativ wenig zucker
das ist das banale nice dafür verwende
ich zwei bananen etwas da peter
kuvertüre kokos wird cacau next und
gehackte mandeln
das nehme ich erst mal die bananen das
ist auch wirklich super einfach bananen
schälen und in stücke schneiden und
jetzt einfach mundgerechte stücke so 23
cm und für etwa ein bis zwei stunden
einfrieren so jetzt habe ich hier etwas
wasser aufkochen lassen macht dann hört
wieder aus und habe die kuvertüre auch
bereits gehackt beziehungsweise gerieben
und ich mache c weder die impf methode
das heißt zwei drittel der kuvertüre
wird jetzt geschmolzen
ein drittel behalte ich über das ist
anders drittel mit dem ich die kuvertüre
wieder runterkühlen also erstmal
schmelzen lassen
jetzt ist die kuratorin geschmolzen und
ich nehme sie vom herd herunter hier
gebe ich jetzt was kokosfett rein also
das kokosöl und die restliche kuvertüre
und röhre jetzt so lange bis sich alles
schön verbunden hat und dekorateure
geschmolzen ist und anschließend kann
ich die bananen hier eintauchen und dann
in den kakao lips und in den mandeln
einfach so ein bisschen wälzen oder
damit wir streuen die kuvertüre völlig
erzählen ein hohes gefäß ein glas ich
habe es auch ein bisschen erwärmt dann
kann ich nämlich die bananen besser rein
tippen ist die banane auf und auch sich
hier in die schokolade bisschen
abtropfen lassen und dann nach belieben
mit kaka und apps die sind wirklich
umgesetzt das ist einfach aus der
kakaobohne tatsächlich und mandeln wir
sind bestreuen und schon habe ich einen
leckeren und gesunden snack klar ein
bisschen zucker ist drin aber nicht so
viel wie üblich weiß hier ablegen und
dann nochmal im gefrierfach einfach fest
werden lassen
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen
schokoladen reste und nüsse und auch
diese kaka nichts übrig und daraus mache
ich jetzt noch rocky mountains die mist
hier unbedingt probieren das ist eine
richtig coole rezeptideen vor allem eine
gute resteverwertung
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen noch die dritte
variante und zwar das richtige wassereis
ich mache hier einen wasser eisen mit
kokoswasser kokoswasser schmeckt gar
nicht sorgen nach kokos also auch wenn
ihr keinen kokosfett seid könnt ihr es
gerne mal ausprobieren
alternativ könnt ihr natürlich auch im
saft nehmen aber kokoswasser ist super
weil einfach das eis so schön
transparent wird und man die früchte gut
sie an obst habe ich da ein paar kiwi
scheiben johannisbeeren blaubär und hier
habe ich das kokoswasser ihr könnt
natürlich früchte eurer wahl nehmen und
zum beispiel auch bei den scheiben
schneiden oder kirschen halbieren und
rhein geben und ich nehme jetzt einfach
die kniescheiben gibt sie in so einer
ice form ist da braucht er einfach nur
eis formen oder auch wieder nur in form
von eis baum passt schon am besten zum
abschlecken und jetzt hier einfach die
früchte drin verteilen
und jetzt einfach mit dem koks wasser
aufgießen nicht randvoll denn wasser den
sicher noch aus beim frieren wir kommen
jetzt auch die holzstühle rein und dann
wandert die ice form schauen ins
gefrierfach
jetzt ist das eis fertig und ihr seht
auch hier
ich habe jetzt hier natürlich auch die
übrige wassermelone mitverwaltet daher
jetzt zu viel und die fülle ich jetzt
einfach hier ein in die wassermelone zum
servieren water 0 und sw gerichts kohle
und gesunde alternative zu üblichen
meist besonders für kinder geeignet und
wenn es für kinder geeignet ist ist es
auch für ihn kommt so kommt's nicht nur
ein stichwort
wie kommen die drei von der baustelle
hatten wir mal immer ein ganz neues
feature thomas de thomas sich unser
werkstudent aber wir bezahlen ihn
er weiß nicht dass die kräfte dann war
es wichtig keine sprüche gegen
minderheiten nichts ging als religiöses
ganz wichtig keine politischen
statements sonst immer nur ärger dann
gehst du in die kirche richtig heißt
gericht ich als richtige antwort das ist
richtig thomas also ich habe hier eis
für euch und zwar hatte ich das noch mal
kurz ein
also das ist rosenborg mellon rodman eis
auf deutsch einfach genau was glaubst du
musst nach ganz links morath denn er ist
auch ein mikrofon okay es war die zwei
herren warum zwischen halt immer
politisch korrekt wenn man es so ich
weiß das schon
also ich kann einem von euch hier dieses
anbieten
[Musik]
das ist nicht nur wassereis also ist es
wasser und wird einfach wie früher ein
ja das ist okay ist dass franco nicht
sogar kokos curry kokos was wir durch
förderung reise aber da ist doch die
schokolade gewesen
ja ich weiß dass er jetzt alle
schokolade wollte ok also nehmt euch
jungs selbst gerber sprache kommen max
übernahm
ok dann ja dann nehmt ihr mandat für
normales wasser eingebracht
[Musik]
das ist doch kein gewesen da hat es als
ding gegessen als das war kein kraut
sich das virus aber es ist ziemlich
fiese monster die banale dinge gehauen
das war mein job macht er schließt er
war erst mal jung hat jetzt hier in
front deswegen hat der einzelne kinder
das eis nicht so schnell lassen
jetzt sagt er mir ehrliche meinung nach
ist es aber nicht gerade für kinder und
für menschen die vielleicht auf die
figur achten sollte okay was ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen
für menschen die figur achten sollten
und für kinder genial wirklich für
natürlich so durchtrainierte sportler
nämlich können wir mal könnt auch ein
künstler genau das richtige dann wird's
auch apfelsaft freimachen ich nehme an
dass kleine als auch kokoswasser steht
nicht jeder geld ja aber man kann ja
sagt nehmen ja und videoservices halte
ich nehme mir gesagt wenn kein
kokoswasser ich fand hier die optik
megafon
das war früchte sind also ich find's
cool aber ich finde ein anderes wasser
oder besser also abgesagt und kanzlers
reden schon gefroren und ich klar
gemacht fertig war
dort hat jörg retten und die waadt 15
prozent
das ist nicht cool ja das mega alle via
schluss gegessen so kalt das liebe ich
das ist super denn je nur zarter
schokolade und deshalb weniger zucker
drin als jetzt also kein alkohol trinke
komisch versteht banane vertrauen nicht
dass ich jemals alkohol getrunken aber
ich mich nach oben nichts passiert alles
was man innerhalb von zwei sekunden
aufheben kann passiert nichts an weil es
die jungs finden das gut
oder ein anderes ding kokoswasser nehmen
ist geschmackssache nicht jeder mag muss
wasser aber kokoswasser schmeckt nicht
so extrem trocken ist vegan volkan rufen
sondern nimmt lieber saft oder kokos was
schmeckt süß und dann noch gefroren
es sieht cool aus aber nehmt lieber sagt
muss man auch mal sagen habt ihr schon
mal eine eastpak rucksack gelegen haben
dass einem rucksack
egal wie egal das ist einfach mein
gedanken gehabt
auf jeden fall cool macht es nach okay
kommt eis ist mir langsam
ja ich werde schon und cake pops etwas
anderes aber center thomas noch weil er
ist lange bei uns werkstudent da hören
wir also was nicht geht